i had a question from youtube they
wanted to know how do you get rid of sun
spots
i've done another video on aging spots
or liver spots and i'll put that link
down below and that talks mainly about
the hyper pigmentation
that occurs if there is three situations
high insulin
high estrogen
or high
cortisol from stress
but i didn't actually do a video on the
best remedy for
sun spots which is slightly different
now these little tiny cells in the skin
called melanocytes produce this
pigment called
melanin which gives you the color of
your skin and if you're exposed to the
sun too much you can develop these
little blemishes or dark spots to your
skin now there's a really good remedy
for this
that you can use
and it's basically licorice extract and
you want to get it in a tincture a
liquid
and you want to make sure it's alcohol
free and you want to use it topically
and all you have to do is put a couple
drops in your cream or toner and you can
put it in a little spoon and put a
couple drops in there and mix it up and
then apply it to your skin you can also
apply it underneath your eyes if you
have dark circles and it works pretty
effectively within a couple days
licorice root does many things it's a
very powerful antioxidant it's an
anti-inflammatory it's used for stress
digestive problems and many other things
but if you wanted to get rid of your
sunspots you might want to try this
because it's pretty darn effective
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it and here's why
here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here what about strengthening your
immune system
that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own
immune system i put a link down in the
description right down below
check it out and get signed up today